[Music]  Monday's episode of The Bachelor had  plenty of smiles my feelings are just  getting stronger and stronger and also  some sniffles but the most shocking  moment was definitely this  [Music]  hello Nick yeah that's Nick's ex and  former bachelorette Andi Dorfman we were  left with a to be continued but we did  get a sneak peek at their awkward  confrontation this was very unexpected  what am I supposed to say this has to be  honest I mean this is borderline  there weren't any eliminations this week  after seeing the final four contestants  during their respective hometown dates  but no doubt things are getting more  tense than ever I'm not sure what's  gonna happen I have a lot to think about  and I'm running out of time Corinne  Raven Rachel Vanessa who's in your top  three tweet us your pics at ET now  [Music]